Israel it seems is now on a crusade to
bring the place back from the dead now
get out there and
we've got just one day before the
castles return to a fully booked grand
reopening
everything depends on the kitchen
perfecting each and every new dish on
the menu 90 fried eggs turn down the gas
I don't want the yolks broken okay they
may be easy peasy but consistent quality
will be the key to ensure repeat
business have to get in there and really
concentrate yeah this is so [ __ ] easy
the centerpiece for our menu is going to
be the most famous butty in the world
the club sandwich when I started cooking
yeah either make these for a living
every day the same every day the same in
just 12 hours time the chefs in the
front of house have got to function as a
tight-knit well-oiled machine chicken
avocado salad that's the ham roasted
with double fridaya and a mining miracle
has occurred is salmon fish geekdad
ourselves Dave and Phillip are
communicating the wedge civilly that's a
stick they all look really nice
the food is looking 200 percent better
but to please a lunch hour crowd
tomorrow the grill will have to fly out
you really need to be sure these boys
are really on their toes I'll do the
toast when that goes to 12 we go go
three times over sweet I'll be the bread
three quick quick
what you refer up a camel come on
tomorrow a fully booked for lunch
funny books Philip it's not funny you
know that also has anyone solve
everybody's bacon on who else is gonna
put their bacon on when tonight hey push
on cooter yes here we go hey presenting
his beer he will call about starting
their french fries goes right on again
baby sure look at the speed of you
fantastically fast is the executive chef
and a come in laughs that's it there
[Music]
don't quit big going to do not quit
you never ever throw the towel in on
service just come up to the top leg and
accidentally drop your plates drop it
drop it launched mad - [ __ ] Munya hey
listen all three of you well done
that was [ __ ] excellent yeah at the
speed working under pressure and
concentrating was phenomenal and the
best sandwich is yours Philip great
without him even knowing it I've just
managed to demo the executive chef - a
club sandwich chef now tomorrow
I've actually got a chance of [ __ ]
surviving a very busy lunch